[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today today's
question of the day comes from Paula in
Georgia my son's school is running a
food bank so I sent him with some highly
requested items such as peanut butter
canned soup and tuna fish when my
husband saw them he insisted we don't
donate quality items like these and
instead only Donate rice and beans I'm
aware that you've told people to eat
beans and rice if they're on a tight but
and cannot afford to indulge in nicer
Foods however I also know that you value
generosity and giving and I didn't see
anything wrong with donating something
other than beans and rice do you believe
that the same principle applied to those
on a tight budget should also be applied
to recipients of food
banks oh brother I don't mean to laugh
but just so silly that's silly it's
silly yeah number one when we say beans
and rice honey it's a metaphor yeah a
metaphor is a a representation
philosophically of an actual item I am
not suggesting that people only live on
beans and rice I am suggesting that you
quit spending sadad gun much money on
food especially eating out all the time
so probably prime rib is not on your
list or lobster tail but possibly even
some Hamburger Helper might make the
list you don't have to just literally do
beans and rice it's a metaphor I think
this guy was just looking for an excuse
to be a tightwad be a che he didn't have
to look for an excuse he already was I
mean goodness gracious and it's not like
tuna fish is that big of an upgrade from
rice and beans I mean come on now and
here's the deal I mean what we're
talking about is you limiting your
consumption so you can create margin
yeah to move ahead we're not talking
about those poor people don't need any
good food what in the world dude ter
seriously seriously yeah that's it's
horrible yes they need some good food
send them some good food you cheap skate
your wife is right your son is even
better learn from them sir yeah oh my
gosh if you're going to give something
away be generous with what you're giving
that's right hly I'm going to give you a
car but it doesn't really run because
you can just you can figure that out for
yourself what in the world you know what
Dave though I I've I've been okay so
I've been here about 13 months 14 months
I am shocked at how many people I've
encountered that think the beans and
rice rice and beans thing is literal let
me tell you what's worse okay 30 years
of doing this I have had precisely
4732 offers to co-author a beans and
rice cookbook with other
listeners I made that up but it's close
to 4,000 I mean it's unbelievable then
and apparently it would be a best seller
if we could just get the people that
wanted to co-author it look with me to
buy it but yeah people keep asking me
about it beans and rice cookbook no it's
it's a it's a metaphor a metaphor it's a
metaphor yes you can this you can eat
different food look it up look up
metaphor it's good oh my gosh yeah but
we don't need to be going out to eat
every night it's some fancy spancy thing
or for that matter for fast food yeah
because it's fast but it's not
necessarily food and the
um and you know you're working so that
you can learn to put yourself as guy I
used to work for would say we're working
so I can get enough money that I can
read the menu from left to right I know
that's right I don't start with the
price I get to start with a thing and
pick what I want price is irrelevant but
when you're broke you
self-manage your consumption not other
people imposing on you yeah their their
beans and rice so oh my gosh yeah then
you're entering into like a judgment
kind of Zone I think and it's like well
just be generous if you can yeah I mean
I yeah you you kind of missed the point
sir yeah kind of not kind of you did did